[Música]
há dez anos eu gabriela barreto e
eduardo martins queremos um mapa da
cachaça a nossa vontade era viajar pelo
brasil documentam a história dos
pequenos produtores de cachaça de
alambique
o que nós descobrimos nossas viagens é
que falar de cachaça é um recorte para
falar também sobre a história do brasil
a nossa cultura e também nos aromas e
sabores
a cachaça é uma bebida exclusivamente
brasileira assim como o scotch whisky só
é feita na escócia o tequila só no
méxico o conhaque só na frança a cachaça
só pode ser feita no brasil ea gente vem
produzindo cachaça aqui há muitos e
muitos anos
há indícios de produção de cachaça que
datam do começo do século 16
nos primeiros anos de colonização
portuguesa e claro que nesses anos todos
né a produção de cachaça evoluiu mas ela
segue basicamente o mesmo mesmo processo
de produção
a matéria prima é a cana-de-açúcar uma
graminha que vem ou da ásia e da índia
que os portugueses trouxeram aqui no
brasil e se deu muito bem aqui nem foi a
matriz econômica brasileira nos
primeiros dois séculos de de brasil
colônia e mais especificamente do caldo
da cana existem outros desse lado de
cana por exemplo também de cana mas o
efeito do meu lado do melaço que é um
subproduto da indústria do açúcar já
cachaça fita garapa né clicar indicando
que ele tomaria feira
depois distraído o caldo da cana é
levado para a fermentação com leveduras
transformam açúcar da cana eo vinho de
cana e depois levado por propagandas
bonitas de cobre
quem também chama de lambics que
transforma esse vinho num deste lado e
depois ele pode ficar armazenado em nox
que aquela cachaça que chama de purim o
branquinho ou envelhecer em barris de
madeira a cachaça amarelada que é muito
interessante em relação à cachaça além
dela ser muito antiga
talvez seja a deixado mais antigo da
américa mais antiga do que o guri bom
americano mais antigo que o pisco
mais antiga do que o tequila ela também
está espalhada por todos os estados
brasileiros praticamente o que torna o
trabalho de mapeamento bastante
desafiador é a princípio só o central de
minas gerais né
mas existe produção tradicional de
cachaças em estados como o rio grande do
sul paraíba rio de janeiro
esse dado de quatro mil cento e vinte e
quatro marcas é um dado oficial do
ministério da agricultura
mas a gente foi considerar os produtores
informais né aquele cara que faz no
fundo de quintal ele pode multiplicar
esse número por 10
são mais de 40 mil produtores de cachaça
pelo brasil
talvez você conheça algum familiar algum
conhecido algum amigo que tem aí o no
seu sítio ou fazenda o andrezinho ali
fazendo cachaça e como falei os
primórdios da cachaça data do começo do
brasil existem algumas versões não sabe
precisamente dizer quando surgiu mas foi
provavelmente algum lugar do litoral
brasileiro o bahia ou pernambuco o são
paulo entre 1.500 e 12.532 essa foto por
exemplo é um em são paulo do engenho dos
erasmos possivelmente um dos primeiros
lugares que se fez cachaça aqui no
brasil em 1532
as ruínas do engenhão ainda estão lá e é
uma das manifestações mais antigas de
presença portuguesa aqui no brasil então
como eu falei é existe muito essa
cachaça também goleira mais de 40 mil
produtores informais além dos quatro mil
produtores formalizados e muita cachaça
no brasil e para ajudar a mapear a gente
não conseguiu visitar todos os
produtores né então nós criamos uma
ferramenta é virtual no site do mapa da
cachaça onde qualquer pessoa pode entrar
seja o produtor um turista e os ajudar a
mapear esses produtores colocando suas
histórias suas fotos seus métodos de
produção por conta dessa ferramenta a
gente recebeu é um prémio do museu da
cultura 2012 e depois de 2014 a gente
apresentou a gastronomia brasileira na
copa do mundo né
isso nos possibilitou a continuar nossas
viagens
então vou fazer agora uma rápida viagem
pelo brasil começando em paraty com a
maria izabel
ela tem um sítio paradisíaco em paraty
ela segue as mesmas receitas que seus
antepassados faziam na cidade de paraty
no século 17 teve mais de 100 produtores
de cachaça de alambique é uma região
onde a economia é muito recente conta do
ciclo do ouro né
quando as pedras preciosas escoavam pelo
porto de paraty e inclusive também o
ciclo do café é quando os grãos
produzidos no vale do café fluminense
também é escoado pelo porto de paraty
então cachaça empatia de até os dias de
hoje é muito reconhecida agora indo para
o sul do rio grande do sul evandro velho
né como o nome já anuncia ele é de
descendência alemã
a família dele produzir a caixa de
sinapses na alemanha que é uma bebida da
batata inglesa e chegando aqui no na
serra gaúcha não tinha batata mas sim a
cana eles começaram a fazer uma cachaça
chamada web house e hoje é um dos
principais produtores do estado
temos também o nando chávez um cara
muito gente boa figuraça aqui que está
em é coronel xavier chaves próximo à
linha de tiradentes próximo de são joão
del rey ea família do nando produz
cachaça mais de 250 anos
a caixa de spam século 18 e é o ambiente
que é a actividade mais antigo no brasil
e quem é que quem montou esse ambiente
foi o irmão do tiradentes
o herói herói brasileiro nós temos uma
cachaça feita até o dia de hoje seguido
pelas técnicas antigas feito por um
herói
a descendente de um herói brasileiro
embora o norte de minas na região de
salinas roberto santiago segue a mesma
receita que seu pai inventou na década
de 40 quando ele criou a cachaça área
santiago e cachaça havana em uma caixa
que fez tanto sucesso na região que
condicionou toda uma economia local e
fez hoje salinas um dos principais pólos
de produção de cachaça do brasil e uma
tendência agora mais recente é a vinda
de estrangeiros no brasil para produzir
cachaça
hoje me lembro que se impunha aqui que
trouxe barris de carvalho francês para o
brasil para envelhecer cachaça
uma curiosidade é uma surpresa pra mim é
uma das minhas viagens eu sem querer
barreiro uma família januzzi produtora
de cachaça
são paulo em caçapava com muitas
famílias italianas
eles vieram para o brasil aqui pra são
paulo pra produzir café para plantar
café mas com a crise de de 9 né com a
queda da bolsa de nova york
eles deixaram café de lado e começaram a
planta cana para a usina de açúcar e
também para cachaça
então hoje no estado nós temos o
cembranelli nós temos januzzi nós temos
o sesi nós temos os campanários uma
série de descendentes italianos produzir
cachaça artesanal de uma coisa que eu ao
longo dessas viagens nem que a gente se
perguntava era por que será que a
cachaça produzida em paraty é tão
diferente da cachaça produzida é no
cerrado mineiro que é tão diferente da
cachaça produzida na serra gaúcha a
gente poderia trazer pra para cachaça o
conselho que o vinho faz e que o o o
mezcal faz por exemplo no méxico que é
do terruá agente comercial que sim né ea
gente formulou um conceito do que seria
se ter o ar para cachaça como um negócio
chamado de território que ele é formado
é a partir de três pilares o primeiro a
questão política né como esse grupo de
produtores organizados
geralmente é fundamentado em algum fator
histórico algum fator econômico
depois a questão física como é que o
clima desse lugar como que são as chuvas
como é que a cana que eles plantam ali
aí como isso influencia no sabor da
cachaça no final e por fim a questão
cultural
quais são os ingredientes que esses
condutores usam que torna pela cachaça
específica é daquela região que traz
essa identidade local e os ambientes
mais interessantes que nós temos aqui no
brasil são as nossas madeiras
a cachaça ao contrário das outras de
ciladas como esqui como um como tequila
ela não envelhece só em carvalho que é
uma madeira do hemisfério norte
aqui no brasil a gente oferece cachaça e
madeiras como amburana e ipê jequitibá
rosa jequitibá branco bairro cabreúva eu
poderia matar meus nove minutos finais
aqui só com de madeira é muita madeira
que a gente usa para envelhecer cachaça
e cada uma passa uma cor passam um aroma
possam saborear a bebida e deixou isso
muito interessante né e começamos a
levar essas caixas diferentes por isto
tira foto pra entender bom qual é a cor
de uma cachaça envelhecida tanto tempo
em cabreúva foi a cor de uma cachaça
eles e tanto tempo em bálsamo
criando o vocabulário para entender as
cores das madeiras brasileiras aroma e
sabor
outra parte fundamental nós criamos é em
parceria com a doutora lina bortoleto da
usp de praticar de piracicaba uma roda
de aromas da cachaça existe rodas de
cerveja roda de vinho por que não criar
uma rota de aromas para uma bebida nossa
e com isso a gente criou uma série de
palavras né de aromas e sensações para
poder escrever essa cachaça que a gente
encontrava nossas viagens então o mapa
que começou com tachinhas ali marcando
onde estão cada produtor virou hoje o
mapa sensorial do brasil né a nossa
vontade é hoje está cá isso né a cachaça
como vetor de mostrar os aromas e
sabores brasileiros
então hoje eu sei dizer que a cachaça do
sul de do rio grande do sul na serra
gaúcha na serra gaúcha ela traz canela
atrás baunilha tem uma cor âmbar causa
de uma madeira chamada amburana que eles
usam lá para envelhecer a cachaça
enquanto que em salinas
eles vão achar uma maneira chamada
bálsamo que traz uma cor dourada e
prateada e aroma denise de cravo de erva
doce ea cachaça são tão diferentes uma
da outra caixa do brejo paraibano é tão
diferente da cachaça do vale do paraíba
que é tão diferente da cachaça de paraty
que elas não são concorrentes elas são
complementares
elas fazem parte da paleta de aromas que
é o brasil
e pra gente isso é muito bacana porque a
gente consegue valorizar os pequenos
produtores a explicar por que são tão
especiais
valorizar as receitas antigas valorizar
os ingredientes novos né que são esses
produtos brasileiros que eu não conhecia
antes do mapa da cachaça e também uma
outra agência é para poder explicar e
contar sobre isso é que muitas dessas
madeiras que nós usamos hoje estão em
extinção seja por via de extrativismo
ilegal mas o que a gente não conhece a
gente não valoriza o que a gente não
valoriza a gente perde
nós estamos perdendo aí uma potencial
enorme
com esses ingredientes da nossa flora
então por exemplo amburana extinção o
castanheira em extinção
o homem do intenção praticamente todas
as maneiras que os principais líderes
hoje os dados para envelhecer cachaça
estão correndo risco disse
são isso me fez pensar é é analisando o
álcool como um vetor para extrair os
perfumes dos botânicos brasileiros nas
plantas brasileiras onde mais gente
podia ir
caramba estado dos países mais diversos
do mundo em termos de flora né
o que mais eu posso usar esse tema do
mapa da cachaça para explorar outras
plantas brasileiras outras sementes
raízes né
e hoje a minha motivação é muito essa
quais são as outras misturas que nós
usamos cachaça
muitas delas até inclusive com é
motivações religiosas motivações
medicinais
toda sexta feira santa aqui no interior
de são paulo aqui no interior de são
paulo na cidade de monte alegre do sul e
socorro essa região eles tomam mistura
de cachaça com que nem arruda e isso sim
há muitos e muitos anos pra fechar o
corpo contra mares do físicos e também
da alma
quem já tomou a que cataia o whisky
caiçara uma uma só 23 a catar é uma
planta brasileira que também está em
extinção a espécie de miss brasilienses
e os índios eles consomem pra como se
fosse um revigorante natural e o caiçara
desde a década de 80 pelo pelas minhas
pesquisas eles ele pega essa planta e
bota na cachaça chama de burrice caiçara
e uma planta muito interessante pela
língua cravo lembra mate é lá em casa
minha esposa não gosta muito mas eu
posso chamar bota no feijão rio enfim é
uma planta incrível brasileira ea gente
não conhece o que a gente não conhece e
não valoriza o que valoriza a gente
perde alguém já tomou tira pô adquira é
uma aguardente feita da mandioca é uma
planta brasileira e é típica do do
maranhão mas não chega aqui em são paulo
são poucos produtores formalizados uma
cultura ainda muito informal e uma
aguardente incrível essa que tem um
caranguejo dentro nem tanto mas tem
produtores agora fazendo coisas muito
legais com essa é a planta brasileira né
e vamos ver joão bujumbura tá na moda de
um gol a mais gente pois é outro
ingrediente típico brasileiro muito
comum no pará
muito comum na gastronomia do pará que
agora está chegando mais aqui a em são
paulo por conta da cachaça cachaça como
vetor de extração dos aromas e sabores
dos nossos botânicos e eu
particularmente fiquei muito animado
quando eu descobri o pacová o pacová uma
semente que cresce a mata atlântica
também a extinção e ele é conhecido como
o caso da bom brasileiro
a gente é muito mais legal com cardamomo
na boca ele lembrar gengibre lembra cada
momento lembra muito o lado lembra
amadeirado e eu fiquei tão louco com
esse projeto e se essa semente que a
gente fez
o gin usando uma cachaça é hoje é que
traz esse aroma do pacoval o nosso jogo
é uma maneira de divulgar essa e
botânica brasileira né
tenho amigas que a gente está moendo
elevando para temperar em carne e
fazerem comida enfim mais uma vez o
álcool como vetor para mostrar novos
aromas novos sabores inclusive com a
gente fez o nosso vinho um projeto que
eu fiz com mais três amigos
o jorge gabriel o joão a gente não sabia
que a gente teria tantos desafios né a
princípio nós queremos uma marca de uma
bebida neste lado mais real que está
fazendo hoje aqui uma empresa de provar
porque ninguém vende né então hoje nosso
esforço é também é entender como montar
uma economia sustentável desse botânico
brasileiro no brasil está falando de
muitas e muitas outras possibilidades
e por fim tem alergia celeste sob a
regência do oeste e leste eu encontrei
um documento histórico ela em prática
que data de 1876 no qual por acordo
portuguesa pé de café e garrafões dessa
laranjinha celeste é o que essa bebida é
uma cachaça que os produtores praticam
folhas e flores e tangerina
na coluna de destilação e deu uma ponte
se passavam por essas plantas na hora
que ele compensava
é fazer uma cachaça o mesmo lado com um
toque cítrico é incrível mas o problema
é que a gente não consegue comprar fora
de paraty a anvisa ela não entende esse
processo tem histórico que tem documento
não entende acha que algum sentido vai
fazer mal
então eles não formalizam a produção
então ficar restrita àquela a compra
daquela cidade o que é uma pena
pra mim é falar sobre alergia celeste
cachaça adquira pacová catar é uma
maneira de fazer o brasil eo brasil que
eu particularmente fico muito animado e
gosto muito é o brasil do pequeno
produtor da criatividade do pequeno
produtor é o brasil da tradição das
nossas receitas e o brasil de inovação
dos nossos ingredientes que nós - ainda
estamos descobrindo e por muito tempo
tinha até coloquei essa foto
a classe nome do vira lata de achaque
tudo que vem de fora é melhor ea minha
idéia com esse projeto do mapa chassi
com e convive com os outros projetos é a
moça que não tem muita coisa bacana aqui
no brasil e eu queria propor um presente
para vocês e também uma um desafio vocês
receberam os seus kits muitas pessoas
curiosas para ver que é não é ilegal da
gente
[Risadas]
vocês podem comer pode tomar é a gente
dividiu um saquinho de umburana que essa
madeira típica para usar para envelhecer
cachaça e outro pedacinho de fora de
catálogo
então fica aqui o convite para você
chegar em casa depois colocarem na
cachaça e extrair um pouco desses aromas
sabores brasileiros
obrigado
[Aplausos]